in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Mitchell joins us with his three sons
Luke Ethan and William hey Mitchell how
are you excellent
very excited to be here Dave well it's
an honor to have you where do you men
live we live in Arlington Texas
Arlington Texas a suburb of Dallas
yes very cool well good to have you guys
welcome to Nashville it's an on four of
you are here to do your debt-free scream
yes sir I love it how much debt have you
paid off a hundred and seventy eight
thousand very cool that's a lot how long
did that take you six hundred and ninety
four days or twenty two months okay I
like it very cool that's your son
speaking of which son is this this is
Ethan Ethan
welcome Ethan and how old are you Ethan
13 so you've been right in there with
this obviously counting the days down or
you just wanted to throw that in that's
fair
all right Mitchell what was your income
during this 22 months it started at
370,000 and ended at a hundred thousand
okay tell me the story
unfortunately I went through a divorce
in that time oh and that's the income
drop yes sir okay but very excited about
the future and I feel like I'm living
right and I'm very proud of these boys
so you make a hundred yes sir and she
made two seven-year still does okay and
178,000 was what it was a student loan
BMW lease a swimming pool and my house
okay oh the house and everything
my goodness so you live in a house free
and clear yes sir okay so how did the
debts get cleared through this because I
hear the divorce mixed up in the math it
did that was cash flowed through pre
divorce and then post divorce okay all
right so some of the time you were
making 370 correct while you were doing
this and then the rest of time you've
been making a hundred and that explains
how you could do 178 in 22 months right
okay so sounds like you guys were not an
agreement on a lot of things but that
you were in agreement on
we were yes okay yes we attended
financial piece together and both
believe that part of it anyway
yes okay Wow Wow okay well I'm sorry you
guys have gone through this but there
you said making a hundred thousand very
good looking young men a paid-for house
it has a swimming pool life can throw
some curves but we are blessed more than
we deserve sir I hear you
very cool very cool well congratulations
I'm sorry you guys have been through all
this pain but what a wonderful place to
land on the other side I've been in a
place to start fresh from without a
doubt what's the house worth and 200
cool all right so Ethan what did you
learn watching your mom and dad pay off
all this debt not to get into it that's
good very good okay you did learn
something then so you've watched them
scrimp and sacrifice to do this and so
forth so Mitchell what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is live on less than you make and
establish a plan and then stick with
that plan you can certainly if you live
on less than you make you can do it it's
just a matter of time and the amount of
time is is how intense you you want to
be mm-hmm and what does your ex-wife do
she's a physician I was gonna guess okay
all right Wow well amazing story and
again there's a lot of bittersweet with
this the sweet parts are certainly today
yeah that's good stuff
well congratulations very cool gosh I
don't know what else to ask you without
going some places I don't want to go so
it's all good
I'll say I'm very thankful for our
church First Methodist Mansfield and
they introduced me to you through
financial peace and I'm very thankful to
have gotten to receive that and and
you're a hero for what you do Dave well
you're very sweet I appreciate that
you're a hero getting raised three boys
by yourself looks like that's up that's
gonna be a big job right there it's it's
it's a team I've got a team I've got a
wonderful family they've got a great
mother we're very blessed good very cool
okay excellent
all right Mitchell Ethan Luke and
William a hundred and seventy eight
thousand dollars paid off in 22 months
or 694 days making 370 down to 100 and
quite a story in the mix so count it
down
let's hear a great debt free scream 3 2
1 it's the right kind of that free
scream it's a good one got tweeted the
other day it's a good debt free scream
if they over modulate the mics and boys
can do that well done guys well done
that's a perfect one you guys would be
so rich so fast and be able to do so
much not only for yourselves and for
your family but for others
you